we're gonna begin with this there is a
dramatic new twist and the controversy
over president Trump's contact with
Ukraine CBS News has confirmed mr. Trump
did order a hold on military aid to
Ukraine just days before a phone call
with the country's leader but mr. Trump
denies putting pressure on Ukraine to
investigate potential 2020 opponent Joe
Biden and his son hunter who used to
have business interest in that nation
all this is pushing House Democrats
closer than ever to supporting
impeachment Paula Reid is at the United
Nations where the president will address
the General Assembly this morning Paula
what do we know about the president's
orders good morning Anthony a senior
administration official tells CBS News
that President Trump ordered his acting
chief of staff Mick Mulvaney to delay
that military aid to Ukraine just days
before a call with ukrainian President I
put no pressure on them whatsoever I
could have at the United Nations Monday
President Trump repeatedly denied he
coerced Ukraine to investigate the Biden
family by withholding military aid I did
not make a statement that you have to do
this or I'm not going to give you a I
wouldn't do that I wouldn't do that but
CBS News has learned officials at the
Office of Management and Budget relayed
mr. Trump's order to withhold hundreds
of millions of dollars in military aid
to Ukraine to the State Department and
the Pentagon in July just days later
President Trump had a phone call with
the Ukrainian president in which he is
said to have pressured the leader to
investigate former Vice President Joe
Biden and his son hunter as he met with
world leaders throughout the day
President Trump said he could have
enlisted a foreign government to
investigate a political rival good I
think would probably possibly have been
okay if I did but I didn't and seized
every opportunity to go after the
Biden's doubling down on his unproven
accusations that the former vice
president used his position to help his
son who had served on the board of a
company that had come under scrutiny by
Ukrainian prosecutor what Biden did is a
disgrace what his son did is a disgrace
the Trump administration has blocked a
whistleblower complaint at the center of
this from being handed over to Congress
arguing that the president is outside
the jurisdiction of the intelligence
community's Inspector General on
Monday the president said he wasn't
concerned not at all
later today the president will address
other world leaders here at the UN but
it's a tough crowd for him he was
previously expressed disdain for
international organizations like the UN
and last year they laughed at his
boasting but today he is expected to
tout the US economy and even touch on
international flashpoints like Venezuela
Tony Paula thank you